you know it's Wednesday excuse me
Thursday morning when Chris seems is
watching film right as we start the
pilot watching the fin just making sure
I'll make I want to make our Bears fans
happy I'm wanting to give a little true
bit so I just had to finish that last
drive for the Bears there I get it I get
it how you guys doing how you doing
happy film pod thank you how you gonna
say to me nice color on your jacket
that's a nice jacket like maroon so I
appreciate you might take that from you
oh this is our first of the season us
doing a deep dive into sims's film
notebook this is part of our flow please
please please please please if you
haven't seen it yet check it out on
YouTube came out last night Wednesday
night at 8 p.m.
our second episode of the show we had
Martellus Bennett in studio we had Sean
McVeigh remembering plays we had your
favorite interceptor DeAngelo Hall he
Hall telling a story about Paris Hilton
and David Hasselhoff I just say I mean D
Hall I just wanted to get him picks I
wanted to get him paid man that's trying
to go you're right watch you and McVeigh
do the plays for hours I know I would
just sit there and just watch it back
and forth Thanks it's ridiculous it has
definitely always been one of my strong
suits for sure do that I don't know a
lot ken it's something I've always been
able to do I mean you could even ask my
father when we talked to him here later
he'd probably be able to tell you like
man Christopher is always like that he
was 5 years old he could name it off
also most importantly for the show for
the show for the show that comes out
last night at 8 o'clock yep is Wednesday
Martellus Bennett I mean he made it he
made a definitive statement he said I
have more flavor than lefke I mean
that's that was the best part of the
show said that his handshake had more
flavor he's talking about me the total
package the total package
aka Christopher David Sims aka white
chocolate whoo
yeah I would say that I have more flavor
than Martellus Bennett negative Ghost
Rider but I do have our lead news story
of the day before we get into the film I
thought oh I have a lot of
Jews but I have I have a source he is
embedded in the restaurant world I
cannot say his name IRA not him it's not
a very big source he works at a
restaurant last night Odell Beckham jr.
was in his restaurant Wow
and he texts me and he goes left Co
guess what Odell Beckham jr. just
ordered to drink so I'm gonna open this
up to Chris you have three guesses what
do you think O'Dell 1942 on the rocks
two limes incorrect okay two more
guesses this is for everyone out there
just think right now before Simms
guesses what do you think Odell ordered
to drink I think to me that this should
lead CNN this should lead ESPN there
should be on the front page of Br
yeah I guess I went something strong
there okay now I'm gonna go with a mai
tai incorrect okay
good guess it's something like that
though maybe it is one more gun I don't
know too many drugs did Odell ordered a
drink at a very swanky and expensive
restaurant Moscow Mule incorrect the
correct answer is milk ha ha ha does a
body good
Oh bones Odell is at a very nice Italian
restaurant in order to glass that is
disgusting dis nothing like milk with
spaghetti and bread he texted me that my
first guest was Shirley Temple oh yeah
cuz I thought it was gonna be I sent me
a real drink I didn't know he wasn't
even milk of that milk [ __ ] old school
right there what did I guess margarita
yeah that was my guess what's the last
time you drank a glass of milk milk yeah
Council yeah no I can't even tell you
yeah every now and then I do it you I
think the last time I did it someone had
Oreos that's what I mean and I was like
I'm gonna drink the rest of this and it
was really good they dipped it and then
you drank the rest of it that is my own
cup ok
yeah I was like hey do you mind if I
drink the milk you put your fingertips
in well you did have kind of a chubby
cycle I wasn't sure Chris coming out
NUMA knows though new munoz not Oreos no
minnows excuse me
Newman as in Paul Newman he has an
all-natural hopeful Whole Foods brand or
yes
Newman oats are great I think Oreos move
on with the time start making natural
Oreos I mean come on yeah but the thing
is is if I'm eating an Oreo or an Oreo
like cookie I want the real thing now
you will be its Newman - OH Newman OHS I
bet you we can get branding for they're
good all right let me go through a
little bit of news and stuff before we
dive in - Sims as notebook here first a
few things about aaron rodgers
apparently people were sharing our zeal
Mike Zimmer on if he's preparing for
Aaron Rodgers to start for the Packers
quote yeah he walks on water so I'm sure
he's gonna play great quote I like
Zimmer now I do toy Savior Rhodes had an
article in the players Tribune titled
seven best players the NFC North
number-one Aaron Rodgers here's what he
wrote
just a few qualities I'm in very
interesting uses you ever see that movie
wanted the one where they shoot a gun in
the Bullitt curves and then he tells a
story yeah well there was this play
against the Packers early in my rookie
year first time I played Rodgers Jordy
Nelson the back of the endzone I wasn't
on and though Josh Robinson was I was
underneath when Rodgers through it the
Jordy went right over my head but right
when Rodgers let it go I knew Jordy was
not gonna catch it the trajectory of the
ball was off to the right then as it
passed by my head I turned around to
watch it and man I promise you the ball
bent back to the left barely missing
Josh's helmet and into Jordi's hands I
thought to myself it's over if this is
what the NFL is like I'm never getting
any pigs a lot of guys have told me that
Aaron Rodgers was a different breed but
now I had a front-row seat for it this
guy was out here throwing curveballs he
can do it from the pocket outside the
pocket left right while he's getting
tackled the guy has no weaknesses he
doesn't get frazzled
he's so accurate always on the money and
the worst part he knows it his demeanor
his swagger he's so confident in his
game that it actually bothers you and
you can't talk trash you have
to respect him because he's one of the
best to ever play the game
yeah pretty cool it's always cool to
hear guys like that that's what I'm
saying when you hear Zimmer a defensive
coordinator that stopped everybody and
Rhodes who people give him the phrase
roads closed and he shuts down everybody
including Antonio Brown and Odell
Beckham right
they just marvel at him and compare them
to Jesus and throwing curveballs that
says something yeah holy crap yeah I
hate yeah I mean I want that is cool
where they throw those yeah I feel like
I could do that
oh really yeah I do I thought was a good
shoot I mean if I shot guns yes the
Raiders were making shows if you shot
guns that probably the flu you you go
into like one of those shooting ranges
and you're like oh man like trying to
curve in like sir you're shutting the
ground you shot the person next to you
Raiders are bringing back Martinez Brian
yeah on a one-year deal
I mean we're gonna dive into that game
they gotta get on Mary Cooper the ball
like they need to focus on getting in
the ball they can't just call plays and
think Oh mark it's just gonna naturally
go there
and I'll say this okay just this one
little tidbit Jordy Nelson cannot run
like he used to so I I be shocked well
it's not a shock it was a little slower
than what I expected I guess I'm saying
to where I don't know if they just you
know they can't have a Mari be the go-to
guy and the clear out guy all the time
no and that's what they were saying on
the broadcast is they they needed
martavis bryant to take the top off no
guy right alomari be that guy that can
benefit from that too so we're taking a
stand get the hell out of here oh crap
first game we really need them call them
back in here get there for a year yeah
apparently they're also bringing in
Jonathan hankins well that would be
another thing I haven't got to that side
of the ball with my full breakdown yet
but yeah that mean that was a little bit
of an issue the other night I mean 39
was an issue really do you think Gordon
was like if we call the Bears and say
we're gonna give you back all of your
picks can we have Khalil Mac back like I
feel like after the game he's like bring
back Mark Davis and call the Bears about
Mac let's see bring him back gonna do
over I will say this I did not like what
Gruden said about his lead up on Monday
about Mac and
today here yeah like he obviously didn't
want to be here see that's my problem
with coaches in the NFL right there that
that's like number one but we fight
against right you know oh you're gonna
say that okay that's like a [ __ ]
political statement and I and I'm not
trying to attack Jon Gruden he's still
my guy I'm just saying that all coaches
do this like no would so then I can say
you didn't want him because you didn't
want to give him a long-term deal and
again the rules are not the same
the coaches never want to coach on a
one-year lame duck season but damn when
it's the players are on that [ __ ] you
and play and I'm just so sick of that
double life you know what am I trying to
say John also has a 10-year contract for
a hundred million dollars so he's got
long-term security guarantee they also
apparently have a skunk loose in their
locker room right now is that right yeah
they're like it's mobility and standing
it's in the stadium and they can't they
don't know where it is oh there's a
plethora skunk in there
what do you mean I mean that is the
shit's a [ __ ] hole the Coliseum the
Coliseum is worse than Ramapo high
school locker room where he used to go
play there you'd have to take turns
getting changed in your locker why
because if I stayed in my locker and
Keyshawn was getting dressed next to me
his ass was on my cheek it was that
close yeah so you think that there's a
number of smelly critters just roaming
around the Raiders that place is like
that's a disgrace to professional sports
that the Raiders have to play in that
and I say that with all the respect in
the world to the Raiders fans and what
they are and how they're awesome the
field is and all that's right well they
have a baseball stadium I didn't even my
little boy oh yeah what a game on Monday
night I love Phillips Garden reactions
what dad dad what what is that and I was
like it's the baseball field that's
where the Oakland A's play did you ever
have to play on that and I was like yeah
I had to do that Miami used to do that
too I kind of explained it I got it
stinks and you get tackled on that man
you get lots of cuts and what do you say
and he just like looks at me and
processes it but yeah it's it's
ridiculous I mean again Lionel Messi
Ronaldo's of the world would not be
playing soccer on a baseball field just
just saying I thought like one of the
first plays I mean Gough under threw the
ball but I think it was like Cooper Cup
or saw or Brandon cooks completely
tripped over the infield it's very
clits don't go in you'll go that infield
is clay right so compact exactly so
metal baseball spikes go into it plastic
football spikes do not always go in it's
like running on cement exactly right
exactly Wow
all right learn a little bit a great
point yeah fill up on the podcast yeah
bring him in again need him for
Philadelphia
yeah what's coming up soon here all
right I got a few more here before we
get into the notebook by the way at the
end of the episode I did an interview
with Jerry Rice a big comparison for
tyree kill he had some good Gruden stuff
really funny story since we're talking
bout the raiders about al davis oh I bet
and he pretty much was like I said what
was something about Al Davis he goes
well the first thing is you knew you
were near Al Davis when he was like 200
yards away he's like we could smell Old
Spice Cologne from 200 yards away so
funny interview with Jerry Rice at the
end it is the goat Jerry Rice but Bill
Belichick really loves to hype up the
teams he's playing this week's it's
Jacksonville
he says Belichick Belichick says bortles
belongs in the same category of mobile
quarterbacks as to the Patriots have
seen recently
deshaun Watson and Cam Newton it's not
far off I mean we did go through a phase
of this last year member in the playoff
game I said they need to start using him
like Cam Newton like that's this best
asset his best asset is when he sees
alas he is a big dude and he can run I
do think they should have some designed
runs for him in the pro in the game he
can they absolutely Shea he can handle
the linebacker one-on-one and things
like that he really can he's got a
little scoot to him he definitely does
so to be clear because I don't want this
to get taken out of context when you say
bill is not far off with the quote
you're just saying they could do some
stuff the running game he is nothing I
mean can't if camp through with his left
hand and deshaun Watson through his his
left hand then I would go it's very
simple say you're right got it but when
they throw with their right hand it's
not uh-uh-uh one more thing here I have
two more actually
Callay escape I like these traded his
jersey was say Quan Barkley and he said
I trade it with them because if he stays
healthy he might one day be a Hall of
Famer
that's a hell of a statement about say
Quan Barclay I saw him say some of those
things he made another comment like the
first time he hit him he could tell it
was a different type of guide and he say
something like Louis Campbell's one of
the all-time monsters of the NFL
monsters I mean again I'll revisit my
first time that I walked on a practice
field we were that I was with the
Tennessee Titans and Jeff Fisher and we
were scrimmaging against the Arizona
Cardinals and we walked out in the field
I did I said the same thing to him I
said the Julius Peppers when I at Texas
when I walked in and played North
Carolina I walked on the field they were
kind of doing some d-line drills we had
to kind of go by there and he was taking
a rest and I had a walk right by him and
I went holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ] big like
I said herb write to him like I could
not get over in a sport without him I
mean we got Albert Haynesworth on the
team and all these people yeah colitis
Campbell is a giant so for him to say
that about say Kwan is like it just
tells you those guys know they can you
know sometimes get just the hint just a
little quick movements the ability to do
like we talked those jump cuts he's seen
enough running backs oh no oh wait that
was just a hair faster than anybody else
I've seen do that yeah so after the
pick-6 force and Arnold I was a little
upset yeah cuz I was like oh no like my
beautiful baby boy like please don't
after the pic Sakura stats 16 of 24 198
two touchdowns no pics and a perfect 158
point three quarterback rating him
underneath boy is it impressive it is he
throws really beautiful inside he never
he didn't throw it off like target at
all no I keep running every time he
gives his receiver such opportunities
for Yakka and Quincy and noon was like
his best Super Ball did did did you say
it on the pot or yes you did yeah that's
good you were quite saying heard all
that that whole day I just look at the
receiving corps and I go he's gonna take
like one shot a game - Robbie yeah
Jermaine Kearse is a possession guy but
he's more of an outside possession guy
yes anoon wa is the Jameson Crowder to
his Alex Smith he's the Pierre Garcon to
his Jimmy G right he's the battler in
the middle yes and I like the Bilal
Powell Isaiah Crowell duo I hear both of
those guys run so
freaking horse that's gonna be a pain in
the ass for people I'm upset that I
didn't go through with it make having
them as my wildcard team that was well I
just can't overestimate or what am i
overstate overstate thank you
is can't quantify it like yeah you can't
not having a host like you that's
special but but to throw a pic in your
first career play and then really just
not bad and I I mean I just don't know
I'd wonder how I would have done in that
situation I would have panicked probably
I would have been like oh my gosh the
whole team's looking at me I've already
cost us yeah he walked off and was like
are you [ __ ] kidding yeah but I
thought the coolest thing was Josh
McCown they were talking with us in the
broadcast yeah he kind of went up to the
OSI and then went up to Sam Darnell was
like don't change the play calls stay
with it it was kind of like having like
a teacher next to you during a test and
like take a deep breath you're all good
yeah him and Josh legitimately have a
great relation to others balls they text
nice call and Sam fat the day we were
there is exam for that Sam sent Josh a
picture of him with a bagel right and
Josh goes you have cream cheese for
blood like they just go back and forth
and they have a great relationship they
really do because Sam's just a good guy
he is you know as good as they come we
did get called out though and I think we
need to address it cuz herself scattered
project FX tweet at us you guys are so
full of it laugh out loud
sim said darn 'old was a worse prospect
than Lamar Jackson so here we are
showing love force and Arnold and you we
did have him number five right so what
do you want to say yeah I mean I had to
have the floor I ever thought he was a
top twenty pick I get that also too I'm
you did always say that I did and I'm
also gonna say it's one game so let's
just relax a little bit here okay but at
the same time yeah headless and he
played awesome and maybe he's gonna
prove me wrong I don't think I'm full of
[ __ ] cuz I got one wrong I mean damn
then then are we gonna count all the
ones I got right because then I'm the
Grand Wizard of football okay so Carson
Wentz or Jericho I mean for whatever we
can go down the list
Patrick mahomes who was on him first
Patrick mahomes me or so so I'm the
are done but yeah certainly been better
than what I thought he would be but in
his Cui's got a great quick release
he's got great feet in the pocket yes
however however I'd still be truthful
about Sam I one thing I still question
with Sam and ice texted Eastern during
the game I texted you that was a really
nice throw - Robby Anders anyway touched
em right and you responded I responded
yes it was the only throw outside the
numbers the whole game and he put
everything he had into it to throw 47
yards and I responded right stop talking
about my friend like that right but but
you know he did he was like wow yes to
go 42 but like hey I might be robbed I'm
not like again I'm not that egotistical
to go I'm gonna get every evaluation
right in the history of my my job I will
say this though yeah his feet are in
chronometer and I want to say this
rookie quarterbacks having watched all
these guys this year right when Allen's
in trouble he does a backward spin right
when the Mars in trouble he does a
backward spin when baked wend rosen's in
trouble he gets sacked yeah when Baker
or darn 'old are in trouble they step
out of the way but I think darn 'old has
better feet than Baker darn 'old darn
'old I think is so good at eluding and
immediately setting up in the next
position yes no he's the he's the best
at that I would push back with the allen
thing a little bit like you can't go off
of the weak one what you saw him
spinning out there I'm not counting the
reigning preseason stuff but either a
lot of times he tries to do a lot where
I feel like darn old gets out of the way
and I'm back to being a quarterback
where Allen goes I can stiff arm a guy
roll out know 15 yards right adored old
knows what I was really able exactly
right I think still thinks he's playing
College yes I might break out of the
pocket yeah throw a 50-yard rifle across
the field that's better yeah I hear you
but yeah you're right though right about
Donald there so thank you for coming at
me FX I appreciate it and why we're
addressing other bad things that I've
said yeah okay I mean what do you want
me I can't defend natthew Stafford
that's the worst game I've ever seen
well I'm hearing a lot of people saying
that Matt Stafford is one of the most
overrated quarterbacks of all time
yeah well I mean the that's just
overreaction and that's the problem with
the world right now is unqualified
people making qualified statements Oh
Matt Stafford go if you ask anybody in
the NFL they're gonna tell you how
special he is again I mean I'm done with
JimBob there was things online making
fun of the last time he's had 100 yard
rusher the last time he's had a thousand
yard rusher you know even his team now
he's had a good d4 there's nothing
special about it but that was horrible I
can't deny that like and now I put them
top five to start the season you know
for whatever reason with the quarterback
conversation comes on when you rank
people people think they can't move ever
like you had Brady three he should be
three forever no like sometimes cool
guys Khalil max better than Bob Miller
some years and then there was another
year of von Miller's better than Khalil
Mak like place and players have
different years in their career where
they're really on their game or they
really see in the field awesome but
Stafford this was the whole concern we
talked about with the lines it it looked
like it looked in the preseason I
thought that when they got into this
game we amassed a verb you saw in the
first the first drive in the third
quarter
where was it's like baby okay here we go
there's issues up there I mean they're
having a culture change problem right
now everyone's reporting it garoppolo's
reporting it everyone's reporting right
now that there is a huge battle between
Patricia and the team health Ian actives
all the same John Robinson but I would
argue was he could have been their best
defensive player in the team last year
he didn't dress he was a scrap right
that just tells you there is truly an
argument they were how do those
arguments happen is it because because
everything that you've always told me
about the Patriots and Patricia defense
is the deal I'm and it's not necessarily
rush upfield it's more of like recon
rockers right is that it these guys
don't want to do that they're not being
disciplined in doing it or he's going
like churches go and hold up the guard
and then when you see the back go to
your right throw the guard and make the
tackle or the right and he's probably
going know why don't I just bust upfield
and I'll make it all happen myself what
she can do but also that's gonna lead to
other big plays and Patricia's trying to
do you think that's it or is it because
he's making him run and all this I think
it's all of it this is
modern-day pampered professional athlete
to defend Patricia here well a little
bit I mean you know who else we heard
this from last year what did we hear
this from last year was complaining
about training camp and things were too
tough the Jacksonville Jaguars yeah oh
we're hitting too much sir we're in pads
all day every day of practices full pads
like yeah these are these are old-school
tough ass people but we saw what it did
to the Jags and now they're all in on it
yes let's put on the pads coach Amaro
yeah yeah yeah so it is it's a little
different for them and they're fighting
back really excited we're gonna Phil
Simms on in 15 minutes so we're gonna do
the Jags Giants game first but I'm also
excited to tell Phil that Lamar Jackson
from my count had 27 snaps at
quarterback in week one and he can
collect on his bet with that guy
hopefully he didn't like cash in all
right right but I'm excited I would want
to know he had about three where the
game was 42 not before I got two or
three okay now he played wide receiver
on a few but I'm the ones we took
quarterback I think it might have been
too okay but that was a but like the
third quarter it was 40 to nothing he
could have gotten three more in the game
yes you're right you know you definitely
could have if that game was close and
Buffalo showed up what do you got for me
Josh nothing okay then we're gonna start
off with Giants and Jacksonville and the
one thing that I definitely told you to
look for is we made all this fuss about
Jalen Ramsey versus Odell who won the
battle before you do the Giants Jaguars
game can you just since we're gonna be
doing this all year with the film study
Papa you run it through because this is
the reason the podcast started what do
you mean I felt like you would witness
me and Simms go yeah the notebook well
yeah what I was gonna ask was can you
explain to people just real quick what
your film process is what you do every
week and then we can talk about the
beginning of the podcast all right so
yeah film process every week I start
downloading games as soon as I am
capable of getting them where you have
to have a special plug I get them from
but I so I start right away on like
Monday morning and I just tried to start
chipping away especially left goes in
the text me and go people are saying
this check this out you know or whatever
the big matchup is of course
want to watch it and go through it and
you watch all 22 and the end zone can
all 22 in the Enzo can that's how
coaches film is coaches film is you get
two views of the same play every play
right so let's just take let's take you
know any place a qualm barkley running
down the sidelines I get to see the side
view the whole field all 22 and then the
same clip comes up from the back from
the back which you call the pit cam
where you just see the defensive lineman
the front seven and you get to see kind
of the intricacies in there and the
blocking the schemes all that so every
play has two plays the tall 22 the
endzone cam and I watch only one side of
the ball at the time so I don't watch
the game like we watch it on TV i watch
Jacksonville's offense for the New York
Giants defense all the way through right
and then that gets done and I flip it
over and I go let me watch Giants
offense first Jack sin' Bills defense
and these are the kind of notes for the
camera I write right there that was the
first page of Jags Giants and it's in
perfect curse perfect cursive there's
the second page of Jags Giants and it
even went on to a third paragraph before
I started at 49ers Vikings so because of
that let's do the notes like that we're
gonna start off with Giants offense
Jacksonville defense which is
undoubtedly the most exciting thing and
I wanted to know how did Oh Dell and
Jalen Ramsey do against each other right
Joker versus Batman so I'm gonna go
through a little bit of notes here and
then I'll let you comment okay obj catch
underneath six yards Jalen got picked
Odell big completion and then superstar
super underlined which I know Sims is
excited he wrote this Odell Beckham jr.
has already been used more in different
ways on the first two drives than in the
previous four years combined yes I mean
he's in a real offense signle it's not
just line up at the left and you run a
slant a hitch or a go and we'll see if
anybody if Eli can get it to you if you
can get so wide open yeah I mean he's
he's going to bear the fruits of what
Antonio Brown gets bunch sets picks all
these different ways but they used him
in so many different ways in the slot
yeah in
side of three out of three all
everywhere on the field early on which
was so refreshing
you haven't seen Odell this open in a
long time I've never seen Odell being
able to just not have to just absolutely
work and kill everybody with his
physical ability this is the first time
ever in a game I said man they actually
helped them out a little bit and didn't
just put him on an island and go hell
you're you're double covered there's
nothing we can do
I mean you guys think that's what the
Patriots do with Gronkowski they just go
oh you're double covered we're just
gonna leave you out there and we won't
throw you the ball no they go he's our
best player we gotta find ways to screw
their double cover in here
Bunch no more stack them and do those
things and that's what Odell got to do
so your level of excitement about
Shermer and Odell is what my level of
excitement the Giants that was a loss
but that was a good loss like that was a
that I like the way the Giants look he
was big hopes for Odell this year and I
I definitely do because there cuz he's
on our fan it's not only is he gonna
have like his freakish athletic plays
but he's gonna get a lot of cheap
catches that he never got before um you
wrote halfway through the second quarter
I don't think Jalen has straight-up
played man-to-man at line of scrimmage
and bump and run once he bails on plays
off everything and you wrote you know
why yeah I don't know why well he you
know why because he's just going damn
I'm not gonna sit here and try to jam
him and if I miss the gym he's gone for
60 Jalen's got a reputation to protect
too and he's also smart and he goes man
our defense is really good why would I
give them that opportunity they play a
lot of zone in Jacksonville they play
zone with some bands schemes the Seattle
scheme the press press yes exactly thank
you and that child for defense it's
right did you show did you believe that
Jalen showed Odell respect more than
other receivers he's faced yes
definitely
without question I think in what way
just by little things like that I don't
think he's ever been as reluctant to get
up in the face even then even on the
pick play do you remember the pick play
where they got him open he was wide open
yes like there that's a formation and
thing that usually the corner would be
up in his face to not let the pick
happen maybe go underneath it do
something like that he was scared of
where the different ways he could go and
he played it smart there was a few times
where they
played to man and he did get Odell at
the line of scrimmage
just like Odell got him with some
natural rubs and bunch sets where he's
going across the formation and miles
Jack you know runs into him yeah
in the end in the end who got the best
of him
Odell won in my opinion he did yes and I
think you know the P I write yes before
the how to PA that was gonna be a
touchdown I mean I was a touchdown he
was gone Odell I mean Jalen was kind of
trying to peek in the backfield and
Odell ran by him there was the other
post down the middle
oh that where I miss Eli missed and he
was wide open wide open and that was on
Jalen - now it was zone but in those
kind of situations in zone Jalen has to
take him yes and when you react too late
to an Odell it's just hard to catch up I
mean Jalen is still awesome and trust me
I'm not
I do think Odell won yes very close
battle though but or there is there
really anyone else that's gonna be able
to cover Odell like that this year no I
think the only other guy that you know
the only other guys that jump out to me
that are like that or maybe the other
guy they got on that team AJ booyah yeah
and then you know Xavier Rhodes when
he's having his best savior loves
pushing Odell over odet but but here's a
deal yeah that was in the McAdoo's I
know exactly if he's gonna be able to do
that in the Shakers one of the best Jam
guys there is you did say though just
there Eli missed him that was another
huge portion of your notes comments
about Eli you wrote third down and ten
third quarter three minutes left Odell
uncovered on shallow cross ela and you
wrote like all caps here like Eli
watching the rush oh my god huge play oh
my god shoes play third ten the Giants
kind of have the momentum of the game if
you remember at that time where you
going man they're hanging in there and
they're moving the ball down a drive
right and the Jacksonville Bank brings a
creative blitz and Odell's in a little
Bunch thing and he comes across the
field and the corner was way outside I
don't even think it was Jalen in this
case yeah and he's way outside he's not
he can't get over he's an Odell is gonna
catch the ball and get her and nobody's
looking at him - so the people on the
other side are running with receivers
and everybody was watching the blood
yeah I looked at the Blitz and
watch to rush to make sure he wasn't
gonna get hit and by the time he looked
up Oh Dell was too fat too far across
the field and he couldn't throw it good
enough yeah you know I just kind of went
there from the start that was a chance
for a big play you wrote eli is so
afraid to get hit it affects a lot it
does it affects a lot he it affects his
throws too much it affects his
decision-making - he's too quick to
chuck it down there was another play
Stirling Shepard on fourth and six Eli
threw out five yards short five yards
short how about the all-out blitz in the
red zone right before the half where he
threw it out of bounds like just throw
it across the field there's nobody there
but he's so worried about getting out of
his hand he doesn't make a good throw
and then there was another play in the
third quarter I believe it was again it
was a zone defense it was almost like a
Tampa to type style and Odell was on the
inside of the three receivers to the
right and he's running her up right up
the middle of the field and miles jack
is trying to cover him one on one
Wow witches just tells you what kind of
a freak show he is that they're like we
think you could run with Odell every now
and then yeah and I mean it's gonna be a
vote if Eli just sits there for half a
second and just watch it's gonna be a
touchdown he's running by miles Jack do
you think that's Eli or is that Eli
versus the Jaguars I don't know I don't
know I do like that Eli has a little bit
more of aggressive mindset here it does
and I do respect that but my big thing
Eli is the big question for me with the
Giants and I know people think I'm a
hater there but I'm just telling you
that's the reality of it can he make
when you play the Jacksonville Jaguars
or the elite teams in football there's
three or four plays a game that can
change the game to make you win it and
he they were served those opportunities
and Eli couldn't do it and that's what
scares me it just scares you but the
Jaguars are a different animal and
that's Julie I mean that should be noted
you wrote F&A like six times just about
their defense the other question mark
though about the Giants and I'm focusing
on this side the ball because this is
what's interesting I think everyone's
how about the Giants everyone online is
taking shots at Erik flat we're so easy
constantly you wrote this Nate solder is
every bit as bad as flowers if not worse
game goes on and no one talks about that
it drives me crazy you know Eric Flowers
has become very easy to pile on and I
understand the first two plays of the
game yeah he held a guy he tripped a guy
one of the plays was the play where Eli
threw it up and Evan Engram went up and
you know moss the guy rather take a call
back yeah um so you see that but I mean
Nate's alters being is the highest-paid
left tackle in football the highest-paid
left tackle in football he's making how
much money a year I'll get you it's like
it's 15 I think it's 15 to 15 million a
year and he went through some phrases
where Yannick and Gao Wei Lin trente
McCrae all of them just absolutely
torched him but it just annoys me that
nobody brings up those things it's just
let's blame it on Eric fires let me tell
you second-round pick will Hernandez he
was a piece of crap a lot of plays to
really he got killed by Malik and Marcel
Darius and uh and coleus Campbell at
times the two best offensive lineman on
the field on Friday are on Sunday for
the Giants was Halabi oh I know mama or
I can't only you know oh man I'm Amma I
don't know how to say his name
Patrick right but either way those are
the two guys that played the best on
that align the other three all had
points where they got their ass whooped
like consistently so you kind of leave
that and do you still think Eric Flowers
is an issue though I don't think it's
gonna be an issue
the Jacksonville's did watch New England
this week Jacksonville is gonna make New
England look like a mess too for periods
of the game now no England's a little
better than the Giants up front but yeah
yes this is Jacksonville this is what
they do this is why they were in the AFC
Championship game they kid with ten
points five per year so you have ten
million for solar yeah you're wrong I
got average first contract is fifteen
and a half per year right and here's
what's crazy about the Patriots they're
getting Trent Brown for 1.9 yes and
Trent Brown had an amazing Gator you saw
- yes but yeah that eights older that
they were trying to buy Eli security
yeah and they kind of it looks like the
Giants got it left tackle what the Lions
got
coach something that's better with the
page he'll be okay I will say this I
think Nate's older has habitually been a
slow starter in the NFL his home yeah
he's one of those guys so I'm not gonna
panic on Nate's older yet okay good
just a little bit of stuff on the
Jacksonville offense cuz it wasn't too
much you wrote their own line holy crap
is it big and powerful and you really
said that bortles does a great job of
running or finding a check down when
he's in trouble he does I mean they're
the best screen bootleg team in the
sport and that gives a lot of credit to
Nate has even more than like the Kyle
Shanahan they're up there with it they
are there it is so good well you have to
respect the run game because they're so
big and powerful up front
even if fournette doesn't play yeah it's
still it's still a threat it's their old
line when Justin Amash you right I can
just mash you to where you have to give
its due respect but yes their ability to
call boots off that and sneak people out
the back door or 4/pi action everybody
flies downfield and then they throw the
screen to TJ Yeldon who they just faked
the play action for they're amazing at
that and bortles is very smart he knows
what he is it's he's gotten really good
at throws under 10 yards exactly he's
got he exactly right or it's gonna be a
fade down the sideline and he'll trying
to throw a jump ball or a back shoulder
and they have a nice little formula
working and it's going good yeah but
overall I feel like you come out of that
game and you go man the Jaguars are
impressive but you know what the Giants
you like their offense you like what
they're doing and they're their arrow up
the art of old Sims an arrow up and
they're not gonna be bullied the Giants
especially on that defensive line like
as big as and awesome as Jacksonville is
they hung in there with them and really
what was the biggest run of the day was
bortles 41 yard run man that was that
was the biggest and best round of the
day yeah all right let's go we did 49ers
gonna call Phil oh yeah let's call Phil
in my bed call and Phil send all in Phil
call and Phil soon dooby-dooby-doo
my wife got her 23andme Oh hers I didn't
get mine yet though we even told
everyone that we're gonna do this you
want to tell you that while you fill in
on yes so Sims got his DNA checked and I
said please don't open it at home
let us open it and we're gonna reveal
Chris Sims as genealogy lie
Danielle was 80% Italian 10% Western
Asia interesting which I don't know Sims
yo yo bro yo bro how you doing I'm doing
well doing well what's going on yeah
what are you doing what am i doing
listen to somebody on TV and let me stop
it tell us I'm watching a Chargers you
watchin the Chargers yes Los Angeles
chargers I only missed it once this past
week that was pretty good are you
watching my aren't the Chargers
chemistry or the Chargers offense what's
rid of you by film or just TV right now
I watch them film I'm watching the
Chargers offense yes yeah yeah dirty
just like their defenses no exactly
it's frustrating and you know I've heard
you this week let's see what is today
Wednesday it is Wednesday so you're me
twice so far Brown yeah no yeah you
screwed me up I can't remember what
day's your onside get up sometimes while
it's driving me crazy
yeah that's why it's good thing we got
what do you call it we can tape the
shows or do whatever yarn they call that
DVR DVR there we go I can't think of the
word yeah I always think of you know
whatever don't make fun of me was funny
yeah it was funny
should I forgot what I said yeah so you
were talking about you know you know
Patrick mahomes this and that so you
know I watched the game when it was on
but you know when I watched it again he
just go oh boy oh boy his rent oh boy oh
boy I don't care how he plays the roast
here he's not enough for me yeah I know
he's my second favorite quarterback in
football ready yes
here's what I liked you know one Andy
Reid still had all this cute trick plays
yeah and in a game plan the living crap
out of it it's fine they just had some
normal plays in there that travesty made
them special Holmes I'm sorry mahomes
yeah and then and then the other thing
is there's at the one time he rolls out
there's a guy right in front of them
he's wide open gonna gain eight or ten
yards instead he just rips one down
about 50 yards trying to score a
touchdown was somebody streaking down
the field and almost hit
it yeah it almost hit it I don't know
when James had to make an unbelievable
why didn't he fully extended to swat it
out and the guy had a Stephanie almost
there's only one QB in football that can
make that throw other than my homes and
that's nobody in my son but I mean
number 12 in green bears the only way he
could do it yeah he could do that yeah
you don't get to do a great
demonstration on Showtime of him last
night but I talked to you about it and
there's in Elma Holmes and he might be
one of those guys yeah he might be that
can just stand there on his right foot
and just use his hand and you know his
shoulder turn it whatever and and just
rip the ball I always call it you know
there's guys that just have great hands
to throw the football Aaron Rodgers Dan
Marino was one you know it's hard to say
Stafford after the other night I
couldn't mention his name on TV is like
that's a Monday night I'm not gonna
bring his name up into that category and
Brett Favre was one right and my home's
could be one of those guys wow I mean
just that man and look he can he can do
whatever you want you want me throw it
sidearm underhanded overhanded high
release whatever all that you know stuff
that we talked about he can do them all
it was awesome to watch it was awesome
Phil I have good news for you oh I'm
getting a pay raise you are you're gonna
get some form of money because I would
like to tell you the magic number today
is 27 you know what that means I have no
idea that's the amount of snaps that
Lamar Jackson took at quarterback on
Sunday oh you know what yes
did you forget yes no I did not forget
but he came into the game oh it yes
there's gonna be some money coming my
way and you know it's funny I haven't
heard from my man where's my internet
are you gonna collect this rather you
have this bed with Rosner yeah Roger is
one yes that's great okay I'll just take
it out of one of your you know or no no
I want cold hard cash hundred-dollar
bills brother that's awesome I don't
what he came into the game late third I
just oh the Jackson look oh it's still
third quarter yes everybody why are you
so happy I go because I had some bets
play at least six plays at quarterback
that's awesome yeah I'm happy I can you
talk about that yeah no I you know my
phone start with me right now but as
soon as we get as soon as I get off with
you two humps I'm gonna go downstairs to
make a phone call to get my money dad oh
go ahead no no I was just gonna ask
something stupid I was just please we
were on the Kansas anything yeah and I
also wanted to say do you do you who's
faster than Tyree kill that you've ever
seen in the history of the NFL I mean I
I said it's like Deion Sanders Bo
Jackson kind of thing like he's he's on
another level of speed and anybody
straight away that we've ever seen I
don't know I I would say he's the
fastest I've ever seen yeah you know I
think he's even faster than Bo Jackson
and Deion Sanders you know the thing
that always bothered me about bo Jackson
and I felt cheated as a fan it's just
man I wish he just stayed with baseball
or just football because I think we were
gonna see something unbelievable and you
know I don't care what they say yeah but
he came and played with the Raiders he
was awesome but I've noticed that he was
slowing down after a couple years yeah
you did yeah I really did look at some
of the tapes when you seemed in those
games you know the year he got hurt
right just go wow he's not as fast near
as fast as he was you know which I don't
know how many years he played the NFL
but what he was at Auburn I mean that
documentary of him right you know I
don't know 130 on ESPN 30 for 30 right
that was one of the greatest ones I've
ever seen that one and Marcus Dupree was
one too Marcus Dupree was my favorite
3439 country that's that number one
junior in high school that he ever was
at Oklahoma or in the pros I firmly
believe that if you look at the picture
of Marcus Dupree with the glasses he
looks like Von Miller oh that's a good
one yeah right
does he did or whatever it doesn't
anymore but no no that's for sure but
yeah but that Marcus Dupree one that was
hilarious and I mean this and just I've
seen it about three times I always kind
of watch it I go you know what he was a
little bit slower his senior year I
thought over his junior year I mean
you're talking about a guy reaching his
Pete quick
and in Oklahoma yeah he was great but
you know he was already losing speed at
Oklahoma well from the injuries to hits
and everything else yeah then also
actually it kind of fits in another
thing I had no idea where we were
planning to go did you want to ask
something go I like when you just well I
was just going like I mean we're ever
talking about running backs who slow
down after getting killed you know for
their whole life is there a more
physically demanding position than
sports than running back are you mad at
levy on Belford sitting out for the
first ten weeks to do what he has to do
absolutely not
you know I know everybody's got these
always he's been paid this they were
gonna often say we're gonna make I guess
he's been offered contracts or whatever
but he's not happy with it
and so he's gonna get he wants more and
he wants more guaranteed and I don't you
know I don't even follow it I just go
alright good for him I hoping that's
what he wants right and Bill Belichick
once said to me that I forgot I don't
know which running back it was up there
he was close to playing I said well he's
pretty close he looked good in practice
today and Bill goes yeah but he's not a
hundred percent and I said well you know
I'm thinking he goes he goes you know
Sims when you're running back in the NFL
it's a car wreck every play right and he
goes I'd rather have somebody that's not
as talented at a hundred percent then I
would have really talented guy that has
something a little bit wrong hmm and
says he said to me I said man it makes
so much sense how does that probably
true that's probably why the Patriots
will throw in like Jonas Gray and he'll
get like 150 yards and you never know
who the Patriots are playing at running
back because he probably just goes with
the healthiest guy well he is a big
believer in that and you know I have to
you listen it's hard to be a quarterback
or anybody and go out there and play a
little nicked but to think about being
next and being a running back in the NFL
it's almost ridiculous well and tell
your joke do it until you're like what
what you know you've I know you've told
this before like Joe Morris like what
Bill Parcells always said about that
after when it was all said and done well
yeah you know I don't know the exact to
paraphrase he just really regretted the
fact that he overused him and shortened
his career and you know took money away
from him yeah that's gonna be so hard as
a coach I mean we did
we wore his butt out I mean we had games
that you know I would throw only in the
teens right because this core we are
defense and this whatever and we need to
start running the ball and we'd keep
running him and and you know I'm sitting
there going you know play action might
work if we do it here but third and
seven a Sims go ahead you can throw one
now Dan but Joe Morris gosh almighty
when he was on he was incredible you
know I would hand it off and just seemed
he could get through the hole so fast
and of course he was he truly was short
right and Korean - ass what's that great
legs and ass oh my god listen I saw him
squat over 600 pounds Wow his butt hit
the ground you know but he was he was a
mate was an unbelievable shape but I do
believe it linebackers used to say we
couldn't seem right and you know man
when he popped out of that little open
space I can still think I can picture it
like it's yesterday 1986 is probably
early 87 or whatever we played the 49ers
in a playoff game
yeah demanded him a ball off going on
the left side going towards the locker
rooms and there was a little hole and he
hit it and took off and it was he was
gone I was just when I said something to
him on the sidelines they said down man
it was unbelievable now man took off one
last thing for you Phil we spent so much
of the podcast on on Tuesday we even
started our show Wednesday night paying
homage Aaron Rodgers performance on
Sunday Night Football where does that
rank for you in terms of his career
all-time
well I it's not going to be top because
it was so oh this was this was before
Aaron Rodgers but when he played that
Super Bowl down in Dallas yeah against
the Pittsburgh Steelers yeah you know
they were still running a basically an
old-school offense at the time right and
he made I'm going to say six throws in
that game that were lasers and I
remember one of them down the middle of
the fie
yeah and the Steelers baited him who
would the safety it was Ryan Clark on
the backside he knew was coming
you know was coming right and Rodgers
just but he goes I just can't couldn't
you know he goes I just couldn't believe
he got it there he threw it so hard they
baited him into it he does exactly what
they want and they still couldn't get
there because he threw it so hard and he
threw the football yeah James Jones at
the end of the game took basically well
yeah Sunday night
one leg 52 yards of a dime and he comes
back from down 20 to nothing
yes Khalil Mac looking like Lawrence
Taylor in the first half yeah listen I
agree that second but you know when you
make these mmm those kind of throws that
he made in the Super Bowl because it's
the Super Bowl is why I call one right
but what he did Monday night you know
what he was coming back in the game and
first of all but he got hurt I'm sure we
were all the same I went wow this is
really a big-time bummer and I'm super
just gonna do to his career if he's out
for the year right and all this don't
come in a year without him and the great
Green Bay is just they everybody's I
don't want to take him off TV if he's
not back there and everything but when
he came back out I went oh boy this is
kind of it's not going to be good it's
very yeah it was amazing and I've
watched done that you know redid that
game it just kind of watched again and
it's one of those things you got to
watch it a second time they even
appreciate it more yes failure the man
dude congratulations on winning your
Lamar Jackson Benham prior you yeah yeah
I got a win something alright you guys
have a good day I'm done with you
alright see ya
be good yeah well I mean he said I he
told me he's gonna do that Showtime
thing he calls me on Monday night and
he's like I think I'm gonna do this
thing with Aaron Rodgers he's like
Christopher who the quarterbacks that
you think can just sit on their back leg
one leg all game long a throw in history
their career and I was like Dan Marino's
like you got it that's right as one oh
he always turns everything into a quiz
game and he goes okay and who's another
one I don't know
right you got it no I didn't say hey
yeah it's Brett barb Brett Farve did you
not listen to him the start of this no
but yeah why didn't he say Elway no it
was great throw her but not a not a like
the hand moving not a flicker Elway was
a baseball play exactly right so he kind
of had to gear up a little more it's one
of the greatest arms ever yeah well like
dad was trying to say with the hand you
know how we just talk about like how it
looks like he can flick it yes how you
know Michael Vick had that - exactly
right Vick should be on that list - he
probably could he probably could yeah I
guess I don't I know that Rogers can
flick it but like the flick of Vick -
yeah Mehcad definitely one of the best
arms in the history of the sport want
you to just let it go
yes yeah I mean it's right up there with
Fitzpatrick all right so let's keep
going with the games Thank You Phil
Vikings we did the 49ers offense oh yeah
we did not do the Vikings offense in the
Niners defense right first thing I
noticed here Buckner whooping both
offensive guards early he's Richard C
mooring people is that who he's going to
be for the Niners faithful I I mean he's
that type of body and that type of
specimen when I say he's Richard C
morning people it's like no moves here
or or get out of my way like I mean
that's not like Richards team or did to
me when I had to play the New England
Patriots he hit me a few times and I
swear I like somersaulted in air like
Richard Seymour is a great example of
somebody that when he was playing
towards the end people would go
Richard Seymour's probably a
first-ballot hall-of-famer
and now I don't hear him mentioned ever
right he's a hall-of-famer for sure he's
a hall-of-famer for sure but I don't
hear people talk about it hasn't been
talked about it I yeah I'm watching the
game on Thursday night eagles falcons
and they're going Jason Peters that's a
first-ballot hall-of-famer and I go
that's what they said about Allen Faneca
yeah and in five years we're gonna go oh
[ __ ] Jason Peters offensive linemen and
defensive lineman that mess the game up
oh yeah F the play up yeah get the
reports they're coming tomorrow okay
they're coming tomorrow
but like they they're their game
wreckers but they don't get the praise
see more 6 6 3:17 Buckner sick
seven 300 so yeah there you go not quite
as thick I say this too but that forty
niners D line like we talked about no
pass rushers right but boy they got some
big dudes up there that yeah come out
exactly right those four you know him
Armstead Salomon Thomas a DN and they're
all Earl Mitchell in the middle like
they're that that's a good four I mean
they can there's no weakness to their
game yeah they're not gonna get pushed
around the edge but you're not gonna get
pushed around and they can power rush
and push the pocket in the quarterback
span what you need pendrick with a big
deal I'm like that what do you need
Adams athletic linebackers and that was
the fear we had Reuben Foster's out but
I kind of saw it on the TV copy and Sims
his film vouch for it even more Warner
the linebacker what was he a third round
pick he's a fourth fourth round head
warner you wrote looks good very
athletic him and Rueben foster will be
all caps good combo
great so is this I don't want to say
Patrick Willis Navarro Bowman but Rueben
Foster and Warner you like this
linebacker I do it's it's your perfect
mix of the modern-day NFL linebacker you
know middle linebackers are no longer
like the 255 pounds that kind of guy you
need a guy that can really run and
Rueben Foster and this Warner kid
Warner's I think in like the two 30s boy
does he fill the hole 6-3 to 26 or 27 he
was a third-round pick okay third round
and yes I was amazed by his play because
what I've seen about the he popped on
the priest short I think we talked about
him a little I just I questioned like is
he gonna be able to play big boy
football like when like first play like
right Alvin cook in the eighth gap and
set him back a yard yes he is he's a
true middle linebacker I do it they got
something there with both of them I mean
he forced the fumble on Dalvin cook with
a hustle play it coming from behind
behind yeah and he popped a lot that was
the thing though Dalvin cook you wrote
looks a hundred percent yes he does
Dalvin cook had a little pep in his step
he doesn't tell he's been hurt no in
fact he looked faster yeah there was a
few guys him Darren Sproles Chris
Thompson that I looked at it was like
did the injury help them I mean are they
smaller guy is it help to be I guess
maybe it's easier to go overcome it if
you're a smaller compact guy not to make
it about the Eagles but to make it about
the Eagles yeah I read this article
about all the guys that got hurt
by the Eagles hurt that are on the
Eagles the Darren Sproles Jason Peters
Jordan Hicks Chris Maragos Carson Wentz
and they all worked out all offseason
together and if you looked all of them
played amazing
Hicks Peter Sproles obviously we don't
have Maragos and Wentz out there but it
was so competitive so competitive that
Carson Wentz like if people would be
talking he's like I'm not working out
with you guys today you're talking too
much and they all were like we need to
be better than last year there's
something about a lot of guys being
heard you talk about the isolation of
the injury but if you're all hurt
together
you're just a pack of Mad Dogs be like
we gotta get back out exactly right
there's a common theme there's there too
there is you know these guys are
competitive already so it's like yeah
even if it's like hey we're doing leg
extensions today 20 sets of 20 let's see
how far you could push these meatheads
you're like when's this probably like
Hicks I'll out leg extension you or yeah
you know that's yes that's the way it
goes in an NFL locker it does help so in
a weird way just make sure your stars
get injured together gather things down
get them all down Dionne Jones and Keyon
O'Neal
that's that sucks finito yeah Falcons
are dead buh-bye they're playing the
Panthers a week to there's no team I'd
rather face than a Panthers team with
Cam Newton running right at you and
running right at you holy cow
that's a that hurts I know I'm watching
kyun on the on Deon Jones and you just
I'm kind of into the lines because I had
a big week can you look at what the line
is for Panthers fast there's a few lines
that I think your days right it's in
Atlanta they got extra days Falcons are
gonna be pissed
super pissed but man the Panthers are
good well Santa you want to take a guess
so it's in Atlanta yep I'm gonna say
with you saying Atlanta first I'm gonna
say Atlanta is favored by one I'm gonna
take two and a half favored by six
Wow you're lying I'm on our chart okay
so like this is what scares me is
there's these lines sometimes where I go
it's so wrong that maybe I'm crazy yeah
it's it's as low as for me the Panthers
did lose Greg Olson but everywhere else
it's six five and a half I mean that's a
little high for me
that's insane yeah I'm a West Gate guy
that's the casino
we're using this year but I'm either
gonna lose a lot of money this week
because I'm super cocky or like I might
be leoric oh one last thing about the
Niners t Finch you wrote I would have
tested Richard Sherman he's not a
hundred percent yeah definitely you know
good like certainly good but certainly
not the guy that we saw before the
injury quite yet he's gonna have to be
careful about like making sure he stays
on top of receivers his change of
directions not quite where it needs to
be or anything like that I mean he's
gonna get better as we go along but yeah
that would be one of those things where
I mean in game planning I would have
brought up to my coach like hey like
facing a 30 year old guy that's coming
off in a kilise injury let's let's just
take a few shots you just gotta see
where he is to see it that's what
happened with one of the games this
weekend where someone got hurt I think
it was the Packers game right where
someone new came they said I think was
wrong tomorrow
came back Amar'e goes I'm just gonna
throw it this guy right away exactly
right which is what you need to do in
football sometimes it's that simple
magic guy hasn't played all game we're
just gonna throw deep on him right let's
just see what happens I mean that's what
we should ask big Phil about cuz that's
what Parcells was amazing at he would
notice a guy go off he'd go [ __ ] all
these like fancy schemes and [ __ ] like
we have a matchup mismatch right here
let's abuse it yes and and and people do
lose sight of that at times it's all
about the scheme and execute the scheme
and sometimes it does just come on to a
one-on-one matchup where you go we can
really take advantage of things here
that's what's so funny about working
with you and learning more about
football is football NFL football
especially is very complicated to a lot
of people it's the one sport that relies
on analysts like you to explain it's the
only show it's the only sport that has a
show like NFL match up we're just
completely dedicated because we can all
watch the NBA and know that LeBron is
better than him like we can see that and
that's why when I hear people give
information that I don't believe is
correct and it because it's not
subjective it's very objective it upsets
me
but sometimes footballs very simple yeah
this guy hasn't played that guy's been
playing all game attack him it's not
about coaching sometimes sometimes it's
you haven't even gotten off the bench
yet
simple Vikings offense other side the
ball other than Dalvin cook looking good
I'm going to read two things here that
are a little worrisome for a Vikings
team that I'm seeing as the number one
team in the NFL and a lot of power
rankings yeah number one from Sims notes
I don't like this Vikings let me try the
guy thinks I don't like this Vikings
offense as much as schirmer's we will
see but nothing interesting a little -
west coast ii yeah you also wrote not
sold on Vikings offense cousins could
have thrown three interceptions in the
fourth quarter yes he couldn't that game
the Vikings defense was insanely impress
tonight but every time I looked up Kirk
Cousins was either running for his life
throwing off his back foot but the two
touchdowns were gorgeous oranges the
throw to digs yeah gorgeous
the throw to Rudolph gorgeous they were
but the rest of the time yes it was
tough sledding it was tough and the
49ers defense was supposed to be a
cakewalk and I think it will be a
cakewalk for other teams right lucky
they got the Lions this week so they
should be doing okay but yes I do the
things we talked about I think the
interior part of that Vikings offensive
line
we got we got exposed in this game so
that yes the offense I don't think is as
good as schirmer's now it's early on in
the D Phillip Oh area and I don't
dislike D philipose area I mean offense
I just don't think it's quite as
advanced and does as much schematically
as a Shermer yes and cousins he can
force the ball at times he can get
almost a hair too aggressive where he
just comes up and goes this was the
coverage and all week I had this window
right here and I'm gonna fire it in
there and you know you got to see throws
at times but yeah he got a little
unfortunate I mean a little fortunate
with with some dropped interceptions
Vikings are a team that I'm gonna give
away a little bit my betting stuff right
here they're playing the Packers this
week what's the Packers strength on
defense
Mohammed Wilkerson Kenny Clark Mike
Daniels where do they play right on the
interior and unlike the 49ers big guys
they're big guys that could also get
upfield I we don't know the health of
Rodgers and there's nothing more
important than the health of Rodgers but
in Lambo yeah sneaky sneaky interesting
right it's gonna be interesting to watch
all right let's go to Patriots Texans by
the way Vikings are a team they can go
to the Super Bowl obviously you know
that I think that Packers are a team
they go to the Super Bowl I just want to
say this a lot of about Simpson left go
faithful they always say I can't wait
for draft and the drafts gonna be great
I'm just saying I'm hearing a lot of
meetings in this office a lot of
marketing people I think if this citizen
left go faithful want to really hang out
with us I'd look at getting some tickets
to Atlanta for the Super Bowl not saying
the Super Bowl itself but the days
leading up we're not ready to announce
anything right now we're gonna do some
cool stuff but I think we're gonna have
I think we're gonna have a bunch of live
things and a lot of players and ways to
interact with us that if I'm telling you
right now in September that if you can
find a way to get tickets to Atlanta for
that week if you're Simpson left go fan
I think it's give me a lot of fun I'm
hearing whispers ya know like we're not
in any meetings I haven't been in a city
let's put the pressure on bleacher
report let's go get it done but I'm
feeling some good stuff John John today
I got work about we can't put the
pressure on bleacher we'll take a look
at a few docs
a couple spreadsheets and maybe we'll go
to Atlanta we'll say no I think we're
going we got a I'm just saying it seems
a left go like let's let's get on those
those flight websites right now let's
find some air B&B ease in fact I
challenge you guys to get into the Mazie
and rent Airbnb ease with each other
let's let's get so if I would encourage
that Simza let's go faithful now you've
accepted liability for anybody we're
gonna do anymore film today oh yes
Patriots
Texans so the first thing I noticed is
Simms wrote down the numbers of all of
the guys in the Patriots front seven
yeah which means you like them yeah I
guess that's what I do I do that just
writes the numbers then I go he does
that when he goes 56 and we get down to
a camera give me your notebook yeah
they're not gonna see it but like right
in the top there he write yeah yeah like
right there it's like 56:47 Nate a nice
it's out of focus yeah you do that a lot
so they have you like too
I'm saying that all preseason though I
do like this Adam Butler today me
Shelton's the Malcolm Brown right and I
you know a lot each Isis exactly and a
lot of the times we don't know who the
starters are until the first game they
rotate their guys oh well so anything
you know some guys were held out in the
precision or they might have had a
little nagging injury so I just write it
down to go wait here's the game it
started finally and this is who they put
out in the field to start the game that
means something in the NFL sure no
that's why I did that
you wrote the Pats tee line is good and
sneaky deep yes and then in between two
stars you wrote Billy bargain never seen
that what the [ __ ] is Billy bargain
Billy bargain is he Oh Bill Belichick
always finds these guys that I just want
to go like unbelievable Adrienne
Claiborne great get you know got
warrants guy last year got Danny Shelton
in the trade this year Oh who's their
starting middle linebacker 51
wait are you finalists rod Mayo yeah
yeah I was like are you kidding me wait
51 starting from the preset Juwan Ben
Lee the kid from Purdue so that's what I
mean
yeah I mean that's where he's amazing
like he just looked look he found who's
the guy that sound on the Browns Jamie
Collins he he's soaked that's the
position where Belichick is the best at
scouting
d-line linebackers he knows exactly what
he needs
yes he's seen the Harry Carson's and the
Lawrence Taylor's in the car he knows
the Bailey fifth round pick fifth round
pick just a sledgehammer of a middle
linebacker just the way they like him
Scout wide receivers to save his life
but d-line and linebacker watch find it
yes and they all they all got size and
physicality and he can mix and match
them Dante Hightower and Juwan Bentley
can get on the line of scrimmage and
play defense and and be totally big
enough and strong enough to go I can set
the edge against the biggest tackles in
football I'm gonna be fine we just
talked about Richard Seymour being a
whole affair right where did he come I
mean it's it's incredible value size
more than other teams my favorite
Patriots d-line
the one that had Ted Washington on oh
that was because immovable because for
me Ted Washington's a guy that again
probably in year 11 people were like
hall-of-famer but he's never gonna make
the Hall of Fame I mean like guys that
are true game changers that I never get
the credit you're right I mean you guys
have heard me talk about like the first
time I played the Patriots right just
like it's I didn't I'm just playing well
I was playing actually playing now
holding the clipboard but yeah it was it
was one of those moments where the first
time I remember breaking the huddle and
walking to the line of scrimmage I was
just like men this is why they're the
Patriots look at the size of this
football team just hewn over a ball and
Willie McGinest are the outside
linebackers at 265 270 and Roosevelt
Coleman and Tedy Bruschi are in the
middle and it was Vince Wilfork and
Richard Seymour and Ty Warren who I
played at Texas A&M when I was at Texas
and I TV can't always show those little
things cuz everybody's big in the NFL
but when you get on the field that
sometimes you'd come in you go whoa like
they're a little bit bigger than some
teams out here yeah and New England is
usually one of those teams just got a
text from my guy Pat Dhoni and NBC
Dallas saying bro you and Sims are
killing it love the pod keep rollin well
Dhoni love you bro appreciate you man
he's one of the best feature reporters
and I've ever seen yeah like that man
could tell a freakin story let me just
finish with the Texans offense Patriots
defense you wrote sound trial
Henderson's a big injury is the
offensive line good enough and a little
bit later you wrote I don't trust this
Rankin's guy at left tackle oh you're a
little worried about the Texans o-line
right I definitely because they had to
move people around once Henderson got
hurt and they put Davenport now at right
tackle who was there left tackle but
he'll let Rankin's play left tackle I
that was a huge fan of Rankin's coming
out of Mississippi State he's just a
little of a sloppy body like he can be
something but I think he's that guy that
needs a year or two so this whole Lions
not pushing anybody it's just they're
big but it's not great quality I guess
is what I would worry about you you also
then wrote Texans have to do more in
passing game they have no good boots no
good screens no and nothing easy for
deshaun Watson O'Brien was an offensive
guy yeah I mean he's an offensive guy
but he's also his off
the basics of New England right and I
just was expecting a little bit more and
I do think it has to be duly noted that
deshaun Watson and he said it and this
is why I love the guy
he missed throws that you know he
doesn't miss usually it's his first game
back in a while mr. Rose didn't move in
the pocket quite the way I would have
liked to have seen him move you wrote
man Kareem Jackson is phenomenal at
safety and wrote DJ reader is so good
he wrote second half JJ Watt is really
good I mean really good eat him in a
reader took over heat so JJ's back JJ is
back JJ was phenomenal list he was
all-around Tom he was a part of a lot of
[ __ ] it up plays where he busted through
the line of scrimmage and ruined some
schemes you wrote that Trent Brown owned
Clowney
never seen Jadeveon Clowney get owned
like that ever ever now first thing I
also wrote I think is that he looks
skinnier than normal right it good yeah
too skinny and you know a little Von
Miller problem a little bit and like
Trent Brown is you know his game is
based more on power Jadeveon Clowney von
miller that was scary and Trent pound is
one of the biggest humans on earth
I've never seen I mean it's it's unreal
but yes he was the it's the only time
where I saw Jadeveon Clowney getting
running starts and not be able to
overpower people or Trent Brown would
get ahold of them and he couldn't get
free cuz Trent was just like gonna bear
hug him and keep him in there I think
what's what's awesome is I appreciate
the respect between Kyle and Bill bill
gave him Jimmy Jimmy Gate and Kyle gave
him Trent right for a fair deal what's
fair deals last thing from that game
that I want to read is it was a great
point by you but I don't know what you
meant how come no one does to Grunk what
the Patriots do to every other good
tight end what do you mean by that what
are the Patriots do every other good
tight end they even do it and they even
did it in this game a few times where
there's not a great tight end on the
Houston Texans I mean Ryan Griffin's a
solid tight end we're not gonna put him
in Gronk stratosphere but the Patriots
will sacrifice the guy off the edge not
being like off the edge like at the
blink of an eye they'll put Kyle van Noy
in a four down front and he plays
defensive end right on a third and 12
right to get after the court
after the quarterback but if the tight
ends to his side he doesn't rush first
he will bang into the tight end
so they sacrifice a pass run right to
throw off the tight at exacts what
percentage of the time I mean in an
obvious passing situation and the tight
end is connected to the line of
scrimmage like that I'm four out of five
times so for me in a way isn't that a
pass rush that helps the other guys if
you're gonna throw off the tight end by
a second you're kind of giving the other
defensive end
a second to get to the quarterback you
definitely are and they're a team that's
all he's talking about like you know
push the pocket they're not necessarily
worried about guys coming off the edge
and getting like 20 sack seasons that's
not what they do
but yeah they do that and you know what
happens to your point what you're saying
there is a lot of times the tackle sees
Vannoy hit the tight end and he goes he
must be covering and he puts his eyes
somewhere else and the Olson he goes oh
gosh he's coming now and he doesn't get
a good clean blocking on him so I just
don't understand like again it's just
another example under it's the only ones
doing what would balichek do why doesn't
everybody just like write down the
things he does every year and go huh I'm
gonna install that in my team next year
is that why he's in the Super Bowl
18 years in a row for this whole [ __ ]
century I said [ __ ] a lot today that's
okay we're excited we're talking about
film I'm gonna give a shout-out to my
job to my friend Alex Mitchell Hart he
actually has a podcast called Mitchell
shares and one of the things he talked
about was free mentors yeah and he said
you want to be the next best whatever
then find people in that space that you
think are excellent and just follow them
yeah and write down everything they do
right especially in today's age of
social media follow me on twitter follow
on instagram read their books learn it
you don't just steal their life right
but like if I was gonna be a coach I
just watch Belichick that's all I would
do I'm not trying to watch any of these
other guys oh I know but I like I've
told you before - I'm amazed at how many
of my friends asked me what it was like
to work for belcheck they hear one
answer and they don't want to hear
anything else cuz they don't really want
to put in the work and know what he does
it's like too overwhelming to them and
then and I'm amazed by that because I
just feel like I would be the exact
opposite I'd be like weights
what does he do let me get my pistol /
so what is he usually doing a daily
basis and what does he do against three
down fronts what does he do on the goal
line but I can't even get like some of
my coach friends they don't even ask me
a follow-up questions sometimes I'm just
like okay fine all right let's go to
Raiders offense versus Rams defense a
lot of people talking about derrick karr
so let's start there yeah you have a
quote here that says I do think car is
locking on receivers a little stop
babying the ball yeah well he he like
has gotten into this like I'm just gonna
flick the ball and put it in perfect
placement every time and he is a gifted
thrower I mean he does have a good hand
and he's a natural thrower but like
let's just talk about like the first
interception right with Jared cook down
the right sideline you remember that one
yes the right sideline the fade route
there it's it's a 13 to 7 game and
they're going in to score and Jared
cooks open by a lot but he throws these
little flick throws and leaves it six
yards short and he becomes intercepted
now there's some completions that he
does it and he gets away with it but I
just don't know it's gonna come back to
bite him you can't just throw these at
some point every now and then you can't
always go with timing and rhythm you've
got to like I give the hunch about per
hour fastball put your feet in the
ground take your crow hop and let it go
and and I don't see that all the time
with him right now
and you wrote this right does Carr have
a fastball anymore there's no point in a
quick release
if the ball takes all day yes I just
it's it's there's very few times and I
chopped it up a lot last year because of
the back injury yes it makes me question
of whether he's gotten into this bad
mechanic with it throws off his back
foot a lot a lot and like you know this
was an MVP candidate two years ago I
know on a 14 and - I know Elvin there is
still a lot of good for what he did the
other night but where are you with Derek
Carr like like right now he's just he's
just a middle-of-the-road NFL starting
quarterback like he's somewhere between
12 and 14 somewhere in that confidence
is it physical I mean I would the
physical need
to improve to a degree and then you know
like the third the second interception
yes my second interception what the f
blind loft throw maybe why I receive a
round wrong route but I doubt it still
don't do it no that was I know that play
it was 72 scat halfback choice to the
left Jordy Nelson supposed to run a
comeback the back is running a choice
route off of the backs the linebackers
in alignment and maybe he went the wrong
way well no he threw it over the backs
head like he was trying to timeout the
comeback he was trying to throw the
comeback - Jordy Nelson that's like
what's Sam Darnell did on the pick six I
mean exactly but he didn't even look and
there was a guy that dropped there he
just looked to the right and came back
and said I think Jordy will be there
that's what I mean
Josh III really enjoy what Sims wrote
for his third interception he wrote
third interception not his fault and he
got hit in the balls a little tidbit I
just thought was funny he threw the pick
he got screwed over by Jared cook how
did he react how'd it get screwed over
by Jared cook Jared cook stopped on a
shallow cross route okay
so generally want to blame Jared Cook
cuz he played out as well yeah he played
out of his mind and he caught that route
during the game that rule right there
they were basically running all go
special why shallow cross and he was
coming across and he had green grass and
he gave all the indications that I'm
gonna continue to run and at the last
second he decided I should I pull up
here and Marcus Peters was chasing him
and it just happened to hit him right in
the chest and he went to the house and
then as after car just let it go and
Dhamma consumed a min and kind of made a
dive at him to try to sack him and his
right hand went right into his junk and
not only the car look up to go all I do
in the reception then he went down into
the fetal position to grab his balls and
I just you know I just those little
things I got bunny on watching Phil
that's why you watched the film I love
when you do that but it's not just uh
it's not just our man Derek who we do
like yes and I hope he comes back
it's Gruden offense yeah you wrote can't
lie I was expecting a little more
imagination with the Raiders offense
passing game a lot of high school option
why choose me halfback option wide
receiver choice right yeah it just
wasn't as many new concepts and things
that I thought
we would see from a simple fan
perspective it looked like he said I'm
gonna bash with beastmode and I'm gonna
go over the top to cook that felt like
the whole office really III really was
to a degree I mean he obviously found a
little niche for cook and cook is
talented I played with cooking Tennessee
Titans he is big and he can really run
as you saw yeah but there was nothing
imaginative to get Amari Cooper involved
or a Jordy Nelson involved saw some
repeat concepts hey maybe we'll see more
it's still early on in the Jon Gruden
era and yeah a lot of that for weeks I
know he's gonna unload them but he did
not he did not unveil the playbook and
he is not on the level of a Shawn
McVeigh or Kyle Shannon or Josh
McDaniels at this point no show mcveigh
Kyle Shanahan Andy Reid Andy Reid right
now he's not at all those guys all find
ways to get easy touches like I thought
that the Shawn McVeigh little dump too
girly was exactly like the Patrick
Holmes dump to tyree kill don't know
where it's like of course get it to the
star and put him on an island and let
him get it and not put pressure on your
quarterback in the rest right think
about some of the throws Jared golf
missed I mean there was some wide open
shots down the field that he missed
right I mean that's right like then
McVeigh just so dialed up after my study
now I'm gonna be creative and I'm gonna
have some plays where you're gonna go oh
no I'm not [ __ ] on Jared Goff if I
say he played average right no no he
played average yeah it's not I don't
think that's what you know why it's us I
just think people when we talk about
Jared golf we all we never say that
positivity about Jared golf I think that
Jared Goff throws a great spiral I
thought that he had a good velocity on a
lot of his throws but like he had eight
or nine throws where he either blew a
deep ball touchdown through a behind
Cooper Cup in the end zone through a
behind like he he wasn't on point and
I'm not gonna say that Jared Goff I'm
gonna say it's cuz he didn't take any
snaps in the priest
I think so too there's something to that
Jared Goff but he did look like more in
control I do agree with that
he was definitely I didn't see deer in
the head last year he's definitely
confident in what he does but I'm also
not reading that PR [ __ ] that Sean
mcveigh's not and his head said anymore
no I came out Monday and I was like get
the hell out of here he's at the line of
scrimmage with 22 seconds left
Gruden was then derrick cars head set
the hole
they're like listen I don't like that
you know that and I got on Jared Goff
and McVeigh for that last year because
I'm old school and I want to be like
that's just not that shouldn't be the
way it is in football but if you're
gonna allow it then everybody should do
it I mean yeah I mean if I was playing
quarterback I'd be like hey John what do
you see right yeah just tell me I'll do
whatever you say yeah okay you think so
okay let's do it
initially with a guy like Sean McVeigh
who remembers everything right right so
yeah I just you know golf golf is good
and he can continue to good and I like
everything he's doing in McVeigh always
finds a good way to kind of get them
going and easily in a game plan but we
just haven't seen that game yet where
can he make those four or five plays
when everything's not working right and
do it himself with some big-time
physical ability okay Sean can see
what's going on from the sidelines to
still be able to tell Goff what to do
yeah but isn't that like if he's
standing behind the defense it's almost
like you have an offensive player in the
defensive backfield Seymour and it's
just like anything when you do it that
much and you're at practice doing today
yes think about when we went to training
kit right he was just floating around
the sidelines kind of looking at
everything he's special a little stuff
on the rams D you wrote it's like the
Rams have four defensive tackles who are
very athletic which is a great formula
if you have small linebackers which they
do which they do yes but I mean when
they're when your defensive ends are
Michael blockers and Dominique easily
just like defensive tackle these OD
tackles on every team in the sport
except their pass rushers are sue and
Donald in the middle right and then you
know as the game goes on in certain
situations they all change positions so
it's very neat but Rutgers is the
underrated guy there without a doubt
always had people forget he was a
first-round pick I know he's a stud out
of LSU and he's been a stud since the
day you want LSU which makes them so
much more studly always does and you
like LaMarcus Joyner cuz he talked [ __ ]
to Marshawn Lynch I you know I feel like
when people play Marshawn they always
bow down to like oh you're Marshawn your
beast mode yeah and he tackled them a
few times and he was like yeah what I
don't give a damn I'll see you next play
that's awesome I like that style a lot
of people have the Rams as one of their
you're not doing Power Rankings this
year as one of their
two three teams I got no problem with
that yeah I can deal with that
yeah the ramps are dangerous dangerous I
mean they are and they're too talented
III need to break down the offensive
side of the ball a little bit more I've
kind of just skimmed through it but yeah
there's playmakers all over the field
he's creative as a defensive coordinator
and you know McVeigh he's the man as
well all right let us go to we did dak
Prescott let's do Panthers offense okay
because I wanted to know how was camp
Newton and all that stuff and you again
wrote down all of the defensive linemen
for the Cowboys and later life you
double starred effin Cowboys got the eye
for big bad deal I'm and dorrance
Armstrong looks the part of de and 93
Daniel Roth Daniel Ross and then you
wrote Pope a defensive tackle and then
you wrote hop said he's the one that
forced the fumble on the goal line but
you do still like the Cowboys D line and
this is Randy Gregory getting a
concussion and Daniel Irving not coming
back David everything that come back for
four weeks I mean when they when they're
healthy and they come in yeah this tee
line is one of the best in the sport
they're they're gonna rival your Eagles
this year mmm like that they're there
they're in that class of the Eagles and
the Jags and the Rams who I don't even
think the Rams have the depth of that
those two teams have yeah but yeah the
Cowboys just got I mean when you have
DeMarcus Lawrence in tako Charlton on
the outside and then you have a Crawford
and al woods as your D tackles and you
never say Malik Collins no Malik Collins
is the backup d tackle how he comes in
and he got Randy Gregory like you said
David Irving there just got big freaks
all over the field and let me just wiper
on this real quick you know is the NFL
like changing their protocol what do you
mean like I you know you hear about
relapses with Josh Gordon and Randy
Gregory
yeah they finally like waking up and
smelling the coffee and going it's
really stupid that we're ruining
people's lives over smoking we'd like
and why are we banishing them from their
support system of the teams and
everything like that I do think the NFL
is taking a new approach with this I
mean I think it shows the Josh Gordon
incident with Cleveland Randy Gregory
there's all these reports out
that has been some sort of a relapse
yeah but they're letting him hang around
I actually think the NFL might be taking
a progressive approach for the first
time in their life good for them
yeah I like them to change but sorry I
didn't mean to change the subject you
underlined Vander Esch we're gonna stay
on Dallas's defense yeah yeah I think I
mean he is long and athletic and stands
out as a specimen he didn't play a ton
okay
this is leighton vander Esch the
first-round linebacker out of Boise
State for Dallas right and the eventual
Shawn Lee replacement Yeah right and he
came in and spelled Jaylon Smith more
times than not when he did I do think
he's gonna be very good in the past game
you know my concern with him it's just
pure up physicality that's what I need
to see more of and he didn't get a whole
lot of instances in this game because
when he did get in it was kind of
passing situations things like that yeah
but but he's got a chance as far as an
athlete he's gonna be a pain in the ass
in the pass game I just need to go OK
when you're playing say qualm barkley
this week and it's 3rd and 2 are you
gonna be able to man up in the hole
there you were also wrote Byron Jones is
gonna be a handful for big receive oh my
gosh I mean he was Devin Funchess
negative ghostrider so you're more
worried about when speed receivers face
him but like the way you're giving it to
Byron I mean I just think he's gonna be
really tough with those guys but Byron
Jones was one of the stars of the game
he was very impressive
he is we've always been impressed right
and wide receivers he plays safety right
he's incredibly because they put about
safety the last two or three years and
that's not what he is all right so now
Panthers offense you love the fact that
they ran it early just because of who
they were playing with Dallas but you
did right a little bit later is that
they're finally making it easier for Cam
yeah offense where Panthers make it
easier for cam for the first time ever
getting easy completions because defense
has to worry about more formations and
concepts you've always been somewhat
predictable and what they do in
formations and their concepts down the
field to where you know there's two
things yeah there was more variety in
the past game and that's north turner
and there was more variety in the run
game and you saw some of the cool run
game design plays they had for Cam
Newton to start the game which is very
smart
Dallas's like that defense that goes we
only play these two or three defenses we
got a lot of studs and we're just gonna
attack the football right and they use
their aggressiveness against them with
him keeping the ball out of the back
door or some of the plays but yeah I
just thought as a whole it's still not a
really overall impressive wide receiver
group especially with Greg Olson being
out at least six weeks exactly
but they got there's people open and the
other thing is you could tell them the
words in Cam's ear to go you don't have
to take six hitch steps in the pocket to
wait for the 50-yard crossing route to
come open yeah you wrote he's not
waiting all day for receivers he has
just been his number one thing is number
one thing it's one of his greatnesses
but as one of his his weakness yeah he
just stands in there will take the hit
and because he's looking for Devin
Funchess on a triple move right exactly
and and he like this game was like oh I
guess soon as he dropped back he got to
the top was dropped he looked he was
like man the linebackers are 20 yards
down the field let me just be smart
right now and get it out of my hands and
let McCaffrey run after the catch or
whoever it was and it was just a part of
his game that I haven't seen him do a
whole lot of in his career you're a
little concerned about the Panthers
o-line though huh a little bit I mean
we're gonna lose a huge question yeah I
mean Darryl Williams going down that
hurts them you know I do think the Moton
kid has a chance but yes I'm argue that
Moten's better than Darryl Williams yeah
I mean he he could be but now he's gonna
play left tackle Motown's playing left
tackle now right and that's different
yeah that's different and I can't think
of the damn kid's name that's playing
right tackle I'm choking here hold on I
gotcha
I'm gonna pull it up anyways but yeah
that does concern me that would concern
me a little in the matchup going on
Jelena on that turf and the speed and
all those things Darryl Williams no
Darryl wins the one that got hurt he's
all I got
I'm gonna show I'm gonna beat you to it
right now let's see where the hell is it
I don't know did I write his number down
nope alright let's just move on I can't
even think of who the hell it is right
now I'm usually so good at pulling up
numbers late Moton went to Les Williams
got hurt
who the hell was this other guy that
came in the game let's watch love coke
coming at the end might have been saved
the show was it van Raden I think it was
73 van Rijn Marie Robinson 77 it wasn't
him I think it was 73 van rotten this is
good podcast oh no no no it was it was
Salah Salah Toulouse salata Lu oh yeah a
meeting went to right tackle sorry see
Latorre sorry everybody out there I took
me a second it was like a lot of numbers
and names in my head all right now let's
so you talked a little bit on about
Chiefs Chargers with your dad but to
further enhance your point about Patrick
I know I didn't want to bring it up with
a dad I shouldn't have done that
he wrote Golden Age of quarterbacks I
have so many favorites Rodgers is one
mahomes might be too he has such a good
hand man the Chiefs are so hard to
defend it's funny buddy just talked
about the hand to but yet he is um he
can flick it he is such a gifted thrower
on every type of throw touch lasers you
know sidearm it just doesn't matter
it's truly special and like you know how
we talk about all the time like teams
that make you defend the whole field man
I don't know if there's a team in sports
in the NFL right now that you have to
defend more of the field with this guy
you wrote Chiefs don't need to be
complicated with 15 at quarterback I
mean holy [ __ ] is he special I mean so
you're just watching this film and
getting more and more blown away.i i
mean like the one throw my dad was
talking about where he rolls to the
right and throws a post across his body
55 yards in the air and the post is
running OH diagonally away from him too
Sammy Watkins and the ball was on the
screws it was gonna drop in his hands
and Derwin James have been a great play
and catching up and diving and knocking
the ball down but that's like like I
said it with dad I there's only one of
the guy in the sport that can make that
throw and that's number 12 in Green Bay
nobody else can do that very SPECT I
mean it's like so even just someone like
the he throws a curl route that Tyree
kill one time and you could tell they're
not used to his ball yet like Tyree
chill caught it like in self defense he
was like I got it oh and he went down
like it was like self-defense be
cuz it just snuck on him snuck up on him
so fast you are worried about the
Chargers front seven depth especially
without Bosa now remember Liege it
suspended I know he's gonna come back
yes but that's an issue that you see
with that I do I still think it's a
hair-thin for what they want to do again
that's the Seattle scheme type of
football team that they need to send
plethora of defensive linemen at you
because it's such a high-energy shoot
the gap type of defense and I do I do
worry about that and yeah I mean lucha
it is four games right as they you said
I believe so yeah I mean that's that's
yeah it's gonna be that's gonna be a
tough haul before they get to that point
here we were all preseason talking about
how bad the cheese defense looked and
then I'm seeing you right down that
hitchens at linebacker and Raglan at
linebacker and Nadiya defensive line are
all popping do you think this was us
under under rating the Chiefs
or do the Chargers maybe have an
offensive line issue that we don't maybe
we overrated them a little bit no no I
think the Chargers I mean the Chargers
ran the ball with decent success and
they protected and you were impressed
with their scheme but the Chiefs defense
the Chiefs defensive front seven which
is better than what I thought it just it
really was you know D Ford looks like
the D Ford I saw coming out of a burn
really oh he had a knee injury early in
his career and I feel like this is the
first time I saw the same explosion that
I remember seeing Justin Houston's never
gonna be the guy that had 22 and a half
sacks but at least he's not like running
with a [ __ ] in his knee anymore and our
man in the middle Chris Jones is a beast
to handle and at the very least left
goal like we always talked about
they got size right I mean Chris Jones
six six 308 Xavier Williams 6-2 309 you
know Jarvis Jenkins six for 300 nandi
6-1 310 and then Justin Houston's an
outside linebacker who's six for 275
yeah so there's a little something there
and the middle linebacker plays better
than what they had not their secondary
holy I mean what you wrote about Orlando
Scandrick you wrote early he's a big
question where he runs with a limp and
then two paragraphs they
you write Scandrick dude no way trade Oh
running back or a wide receiver they get
they gotta make a move like dirt it just
it's not gonna get it done he's got no
chance I don't mean to me mean to
Orlando Scandrick but there's a reason
he's on his third team this season
exactly he was on the Cowboys in
Washington yes
that's it's really I mean everybody what
do you mean like how bad like he's not
gonna be able to cover anybody
man-to-man well there luckily they're
not playing a good passing office
luckily it's gonna be Antonio Brown with
him one on one
yeah he's got no chance and he's been a
really good player for a long time and I
don't like saying these kind of things
but his knee is not right he has no
explosion and he has no top-end speed
anymore so he's a guy that wasn't right
but took the Chiefs money unlike you
yeah they need Eric Barry back because
then they can move Eric Murray who's
playing safety there right now to the
other corner at least to help out do the
Chiefs have a chance to really win the
AFC West I think they do that game is at
least gonna change my opinion a little
bit I'm not sure I mean the AFC West is
still up for grabs
but but from your notes you're a little
bit unsure about the Chargers ol line
yeah but you are very impressed with
their scheme oh my god they're very
impressed with Melvin Gordon you wrote
the Chargers have the best pass down
field passing design in the NFL I've
never seen a team that can find more
ways to get 20-yard 30-yard completions
ever they can do it so many different
ways that's very impressive but you're
worried about some of the guards on the
Chargers you're worried about the depth
on the D line you're seeing holes on
them and the Chiefs I mean granted they
looked really good right but the Chiefs
a lot will depend on their ability to be
an explosive offensive football team
they're gonna have to pressure that
right they have to play through that and
then can he be smart consistently
through the air all those throws 27
throws let me just tell you had two
drops that were phenomenal throws too
but he talked about my homes or homes my
homes my homes made one stupid play and
he got lucky it didn't get intercepted
other that he was really good and Rivers
was phenomenal their pass game so now I
worry about Dan Feeny at left guard
yes but they should be having forest
lamp come
I would think I know that he's gonna be
back in the fold here soon and the other
thing I wrote with rivers is just like
man he's so awesome and they're in so
many games cuz of him
but guys can he throw himself out of the
game man he just I just feel like the
last two or three years at the biggest
moment where you go here they go they
got the game back and draw through the
interception I just kind of feel like
that's been his thing where he brings
them back to get him to go here they
come and then he makes that pad pick
though they kind of had the momentum and
maybe the game swinging back into there
what is the reason is that a mental
thing
he's just so aggressive there's so much
on him at times because their defense
gets off to a bad start and they heard
all of a sudden that's 14-nothing it's
like okay I gotta start I guess start
pushing the air all revved up and focus
then my thing is you you need him to be
that way you do but then once the game
is back in hand you need him to go back
right but he never turns it off he's not
he does not you're exactly right that's
exactly the the point he has to take
chances he doesn't really want to take
and then he gets going and then you want
to go dude we made it back we're okay
chill stop throwing the floaters up and
relying on 50/50 balls I think we got
through all your notes I think we did it
nice
so let's before we're gonna make this
bet on the Friday Pakistan the betting
show but Bengals Ravens
I just want to preview it because this
comes out Thursday morning don't make
your bet or where you're leaning but
let's go bangles offense Ravens defense
it'll be interesting Joe Mixon it's the
first time that the Bengals have had a
bell cow running back in the last four
years
usually it's Helen Giovanni splitting it
Annie Dalton looked really good able to
find AJ Green and I think if you take
away the Andy Dalton pick in the
beginning and the AJ Green fumble that
offense was really clicking right the
Ravens defense a lot of depth Jimmy
Smith is still out Willie Henry's gonna
be out of this game
mari's Kennedy's gonna be out of this
game too cornerback but the Ravens D
it's hard because they just played the
bills yeah but we know what they're
capable of Bengals offense Ravens D how
do you see that that side of the ball
yeah III think a lot of this Ravens
defense right now even with Jimmy Smith
being out I think they have enough cover
guys because tavon Youngs back in the
equation and Anthony Levine's back in
the equation Tony Jefferson
one of those guys I could do a little
bit of everything can cover even when
you got to so I look at that held AJ
Green and checked the last two times
they have and I think the other thing
too is you know the bangles old line is
still a little bit of a question mark
for me okay yeah I'm not gonna put too
much stock in against them then blocking
the Colts right right right so you know
I know I know you like Kimiko Turin I do
like him but this is the Ravens and
they're deep on the D line and not
necessarily I'm gonna say in the
category of the Jags of the Eagles but
but the Ravens are so deep that when
they cut a deal I'm and people put in
waiver yeah exactly right they put into
it and their dirty line is so big and so
physical then they can just steamroll
you at times if you're not careful so I
look at that and go I'm gonna ride with
the Ravens defense over the Bengals
offense there and that matchup
maybe maybe John Ross pops one off or
something like that right right exactly
right maybe Tyler Eifert in the red zone
but favorable matchup I think it could
be hard on Thursday night I think so too
and then you know the Ravens on the
other side of the ball Ravens offense
looked really good and and there there
are certain teams that we get to jump on
for three to four weeks because people
aren't ready to accept it yeah we got
three four weeks of the Saints last year
before people realized what was good
people are gonna go maybe Joe Flacco is
good we've been telling you for four
weeks this is a different Joe Flacco
he's getting the ball out quick right
the offensive line is completely healthy
fantasy wise John Brown always doing
well looks good Willie Sneed looks
healthy was not healthy last year for
the Saints member it was also spent a
year Crabtree and the number one tight
end right now for the Ravens is his kid
Nick Boyle all right and he's getting
more of the targets and he looks good
offense looks good
Bengals defense Bengals defense looked
pretty good too real a lot of athletes
really good pass rushers really good
defensive tackles still Novant as
perfect secondary we all know they can
match up with any of anybody none of
those Ravens receivers are gonna get
open right and they got some pretty good
safeties too they do how do you think
about the Ravens offense Bengals defense
and I like to say that typically
on a Thursday night game yeah the
defense at home has an advantage just
typically pans out that way doesn't seem
that way I always think of you when I
think Thursday night games because
you've beaten my ass in them so many
times yeah but it took me getting losing
and it took me really right seeing the
bills beat that lose to the Jets in New
York right when the bills are on a run
the Jets tongue and that was the Jets
dancing defense game where I was like
these defensive team Ravens beat the
Dolphins 40 to nothing in Baltimore like
where the hell to defense at home wins
on Thursday there's no doubt and the
team that has to travel on that short
week that's a huge disadvantage to them
as well I do like this bangles defense
their corners their three corners are
you know that's that's as good a trio as
there is I mean that's phenomenal I
think still at the end of the day I
think the Ravens old line is the type of
online that can handle that d-line and
Billings and Atkins from really just
just disrupting things up the middle
right I don't think that the Bengals
they have more of the power rushers on
the outside right that's not the guys
that turn the edge and the Von Miller
doesn't overpower but what about Lawson
lost Fawcett is do but Lawson doesn't
nobody start either so I think he comes
in maybe he started less I think he did
start last week because they let go of
Michael Johnson there but he came back I
know he did I know I did and um yeah so
I don't know I'm just so high on the
Ravens it's hard for me not to pick them
when I'm not gonna go fill lasers
offense a whole lot of credit until I
see more or even started off to no last
year yeah had ten interceptions there's
some like that in the first two games so
they can start off fast the other thing
how much do you factor this the Ravens
got to set all their starters in the
second half I know I think it's a huge
big especially with a short week huge
deal on a short week it is and they've
been smart all preseason that's all we
heard them talk about is Harbaugh being
smart with the older gonna start and
they were finally healthy right not and
man let them ease into it right and
they're big and they're physical and
yeah I mean I think the Ravens are I'm
gonna say it I mean I think they're one
of the best teams in the sport I really
do I think they're gonna be in this to
the very end this year they're the
number one team that when I made my pick
I mean I get
[ __ ] for the Cowboys and man if I could
take back that cowboy spec right now I
would but the Ravens are the other one
that people want we have one yeah well I
mean the Cowboys were everything I
feared in week one but the Ravens are
the team that I think people like the
Ravens they stink the other thing that I
just like to say is Randy Bullock versus
Justin Tucker sure if we're getting into
a field goal batter and it's AFC North I
got 20 more yards of Justin Tucker yeah
he's definitely gonna win the field
little batter that's for sure is that
what I said yeah yeah Texas guy oh they
always win the batteries you know
they're matter champ my thing is if you
watch the show you saw that my man Ally
white picked the Raven I picked the
Bengals at home so I'm gonna be rooting
but when we make our picks tomorrow I
think everyone can kind of see where
we're both leaning yes I just know that
I don't think either of us are big
Thursday Night Football betters just
like alright can I just read off some of
the size of the people on the Ravens
real quickly where we go okay
Brandon Williams 6-1 340 Michael 3 on
there's not a lot of three 40s there's a
lot of 310 yeah well there's one right
next to him okay Michael Pearce 6 4 3 6
foot 3 48 inch shorter same weight
that's not that's their starting D
tackle all 6-foot 340 yes that's why
when you go why can't they get a push up
the middle on the Ravens you want to go
because you need a bulldozer to move
those two it's 7 it's over 700 pounds of
man-meat in the middle ok they got guys
like Chris swarm Leah that hurdy ends
that r65 300 there outside linebackers
jew donna za'darius Smith are both
six-three six-four 275 ok yes you know
you get into the tackles of Ronnie
Stanley 6 6 3 20 March L yonder 6 3 3:05
Alex Lewis 6 6 3:15 Jermaine Elmen
you're 6 4 3:30 so we talk all the time
about the the loss of the 300 pounders
in the NFL yes they've all gone to
Baltimore apparently yeah well because
Baltimore has a lot of that New England
principle where they they err on sighs
it goes back
or an old saying say it baby fast people
get slow as the season goes long big
people don't get smaller
Pam SIA and the show we out that was
great and I just want to say this we we
always on our Wednesday film podcast get
a lot of people that go why didn't you
talk about our team I know when we do
the betting show tomorrow we're gonna
get into a lot of the in-depth stuff the
true thing is is it takes about 2 to 3
hours to watch a game on film and we
went through we went to games once we
could really go through and we didn't
give Washington Arizona anything I know
we wanted to get there like what's an
iamb tennis I know I'm dying to get
there but it's with this season's only
been oh I mean the games have only been
done for like over 48 hours there's only
so much film I can deep down that's why
when when we do our picks
we're gonna go to every team yeah we're
gonna go deeper on those teams and we're
gonna make sure that we go over because
I think when we make our picks we end up
going ok let's talk about their deal and
talk about their linebackers let's talk
about their secondary but I'm noticing a
lot of people were upset last week
they're like where'd all the podcast go
now you're seeing how much we're gonna
do this season yeah Tuesday
recap Wednesday show please go on
youtube and watch it over 450,000 people
watched it last week I am we're really
proud of it and you need to see the
beginning with Aaron Rodgers Thursday
deep dive in the film notebook Friday
bedding show and we need to keep going
Sims went 9 and 7 in his bets 9 and 7
left go went 12 and 4 damn how much
money you up on me nah I'm up 900 and
you're I think down 80 ok ok I'm almost
up a thousand I got a dime I can I buy
back to even right now I got eighty cash
and a bleacher bank is open all day
banks is actually taking money out of
his pocket guys hope the cash away hope
you enjoyed it
Oh big buck Sims over there areas yeah
nice wall out there to all the homies we
appreciate you good luck in your Sims
ileft go Football League by the way who
are we playing oh we won our first match
because Matt Prater couldn't score 5
happens
Phantasy Sims yeah big-time Odell Rogers
is one enough wanna know how you like
that and coming up this week I'm loading
up our matchup we're playing a team
named Sims is 236 the ranked QB is the
name of the team were playing Blake
bortles brothers that were playing this
week all right for Sims seats out homie
or pendrick good evening everybody
and the lef koe man holla holla holla
holla holla holla we will talk to you
tomorrow be well be easy be good Jerry
Rice how you doing pal I'm doing good
how you doing oh man it's great here in
your voice those sultry tones everything
in my eardrums that's that country
accent I know it's really really good
Jerry you're here from Marriott and we
appreciate Marriott I want to let you
know that after having spoken to you a
few times and reading about you the
thing I like about you the most is
you're a man that has rituals
you-you-you have a routine I'm curious
what time did you wake up today I didn't
sleep at all I just leave it all because
I knew this moment it was real special
to me to work with Marriott and also the
Lord he program and I'm looking for my
man this is crazy because I'm looking
for my master class I can't wait for
that master class to happen because it's
gonna be in Atlanta Georgia on December
17
it's a punt pass and kick I get a chance
to interact with some of the members I
get a chance to take them through a
workout we're gonna have a great time
but you know you have to go to moments
dot Marriott Rewards calm and get all
that information and you know it's great
working with a Marriott that's awesome
all right back to your rituals do you
eat the same thing every Thursday no I
do not eat the same thing every Thursday
I don't know that's why I'm asking I
don't know I feel like you're someone
that has perfected your habits do you
have any bad habits
of course I do like what I'm not gonna
tell you one day
I can't just close that to you go ahead
all right next question
I'm sure you watch the 49ers I watch
them and I go man this offensive system
it reminds me back when you were playing
I just see guys wide open does that
excite you not only as someone that is a
beloved 49er but just a fan of offensive
football well as receivers we always are
open hmm but I think with I think with
the Niners now is like run pass option
it's a totally different from the West
Coast offense back in the day but you
know you still got players in position
where they can make plays and it's a
passing league now the ball is more in
the air and it's gotta be more
opportunities for receivers not only is
it a passing league Jerry these
contracts are different than when you
played I'm just gonna read this to you
and I want your reaction this is what
Odell got 95 million 65 guaranteed yeah
I had to do with a lot of guys that
paved the way for him and you know
because even the money that I made there
was guys before me that I did I think so
you know I think with Odell Beckham what
he brings to the game he says he's a key
figure when you think about this on on
that team the New York giant you think
about the New York Giants you think
about Odell Beckham and what he does on
the football field so he's the face up
that France franchise and you know I
take my head off Shawn I think the thing
with wide receivers is everybody always
wants to compare you guys but I love
when there's wide receiving cores where
they complement each other and I'm
curious if I'm building my ultimate
roster Jerry Rice has won a hundred
percent on one side who would you want
to be on your other side that you think
would compliment you well that's maybe
playing today that's planned today I
would say probably Julio Jones or
Antonio Brown hmm what what do you think
you and Julio would be like oh my god
that he's about six five four three four
four something like that just can fly
just go off the line of scrimmage he
reminds me a lot of Terrell Owens and
you know he can make plays so that would
be really exciting and then what would
it be like to play with a because now
that's a different kind of offense yeah
you know a quick guy off the line of
scrimmage said you know that that you
know very flashy he has this he's cocky
in a way but you know I think all
receivers are like that but you know
that this guy's gonna make plays on the
opposite side then if it's Odell Beckham
or something like that you know the
one-handed catch he he could to run
after after the catch you know he could
put points on the boys so you know just
great receivers we have in our minds I
the look of a wide receiver a little
long a long stride and then there's this
guy Tyreke Hill who's half running back
half wide receiver he runs like a 4 -
but he's not up there at Y receivers but
Simms and I when we do the show we go
he's one of the best out there yeah we
killed yeah how do you how do you
evaluate a guy like that because he's
not the typical wide receiver yeah he's
not a typical guy but you have to double
this guy he's so fast and and it was
doing a play he reminded me a lot of bo
Jackson I remember bo Jackson running
down the sidelines I think was against
the Seattle Seahawks of me like that
it's like everybody everyone else they
were standing still and he'll he's the
same way he's just as fast and the
team's gonna have to start to double
this guy and try to take him out of the
game
Jerry is there who is your second
favorite team in the NFL if the Niners
are your first it would have to be the
Raiders it's gotta be the Raiders yeah
a lot of people are coming for Gruden's
neck right now and I know you're gonna
defend them and I'd love you to but
people are saying he's crazy
that is Jerry Rice saying no no Jon
Gruden what he brings to the table I
think the players they have bought in
yes they went up against the Rams and
they took one on the chance yeah but
they're gonna bounce back and they're
gonna win some games this season and I
think it has a lot to do with John groom
see so I work with Chris Sims and he
played under Gruden for a long time and
he always he has great stories and I'm
curious do you have a Gruden story that
you think personifies what
it's like to play wide receiver for Jon
Gruden well he's Chucky
you can he can change on you he keeps
you pretty much on your toes and was
there a time that you were the most on
your toes oh yes always because you know
we had a lot of terminology that we had
to sort of you know you had to be able
to with the terminology be able to line
up on a line of scrimmage so if you miss
one word you wouldn't know where to go
so you know Jon Gruden and I we had yeah
some conversations not very nice but you
know but I've respected him and I wanted
to go out there and play football for
that man I feel like in a weird way not
having nice words might make Gruden like
you more you know I feel like he likes
guys that go back in fact with hey you
know you know I think he wants guys that
that's gonna go out there in battle
weekend and we go you know not not on
Sundays and not on Monday Night Football
yeah doing the games and stuff like that
but also doing practice because that's
really gonna put them in a position
where they know they can win I feel like
I'm gonna wrap it up here everyone has
an interaction with Al Davis that they
remember fondly what would yours be
I think the Old Spice Cologne is
something like that so you could how far
away could you smell out I could smell
him in a second he walked out of the
locker room and we really like we could
be 200 yards out there at practice and
you're smelling Old Spice Camille is
that smell in the air that is we do that
al Davis that he was you know walking on
to the football field and when he saw
when he signed you did he say anything
that you remembered I think when he
signed me we talked for about 45 minutes
to an hour Wow at a location and he
still knew that I had the desire in the
fire to uh you know play football that's
awesome and that's like the vote of
confidence because al gave us new
football people don't realize that yeah
he knew football and and he would always
call me up to his office and try to pick
my brain that's awesome Jerry you're the
man again Marriott Rewards the
in Atlanta what is it again 7:17
assembler 17 and you get a master class
from Jerry Rice what are you gonna teach
him hand placement everything line
segment coming off the line of scrimmage
we gonna rhyme we're gonna we're gonna
make a sweat and like I say go to moment
dot Marriott Rewards calm and get all
that information teach them how to have
those perfect cornrows for a long time
I love it Jerry you're the man dude have
an awesome day you too